as tens of millions of americans
consider getting a booster shot the
demand for coveted tests is also growing
our dr tara narula joins us now with
what you need to know i want to get to
testing in a second but for now the
booster shot what exactly changed to
lead to this new recommendation exactly
well there were two messages that really
came across loud and clear if you
listened to the briefing yesterday one
was about transparency we heard dr
murphy say when we see a signal we will
tell you and the other was about being
proactive with dr fauci saying if you
wait for something bad to happen before
you respond you're not going to be able
to respond with your fullest
capabilities so they really cited the
science and the data emerging data as as
recent as the last couple days both in
this country and abroad as really
pushing them to change and the data
shows that effectiveness in terms of the
vaccine for mild and moderate disease
does go down that there's decreased
vaccine effectiveness for delta and the
good news being that we know for severe
disease hospitalization and death it
does seem that there's high
effectiveness that effectiveness is
stable but what they said is the concern
is that the trajectory the pattern
they're seeing indicates that it's
possible that in the future
even people who are vaccinated could be
vulnerable to developing severe disease
they also just want to say they also
utilized antibody and immunologic data
in their discussion i think it's
important to understand that they show
that antibody levels decline higher
antibody levels associated with better
efficiency when you give a boost you get
a 10 fold or more increase in antibody
level so how will the booster shots be
rolled out well i think the most
important thing understand is that this
does have to go through the fda first
they need to do an independent review
the cdc's a sub committee also has to
review this and make their
recommendations if that goes through
then in mid-september 18 years and over
eight months post your second dose if
you got the pfizer or moderna vaccine
and you fall into that first priority
group so healthcare workers or
front-line workers nursing home or
seniors you will be eligible ideally you
would get the same type that you had
before they did say as you heard dr
wolenski this morning that the johnson
and johnson data they will be reviewing
and ideally in the future hopefully they
will be asking those individuals to get
a booster
and they hope to roll this out at over
80 000 locations in the country and
administer over 100 million doses in the
next coming months what are your
thoughts about cobit testing for
vaccinated people i'm getting one today
because i'm hosting that thing uh on
central park and we have to have a we
have to show proof but i always thought
if you're vaccinated you can stop
getting the kova test that has changed
this is such a good point and i think
it's confusing for a lot of people
vaccines have never been the end game
testing has always been a critical part
of this battle and i think we've really
failed as a country to really accept
that and for people to understand that
but now we have data showing number one
there are breakthrough infections for
vaccine individuals number two
vaccinated individuals can transmit to
others so this is about getting tested
in part to protect those around you who
may be vulnerable and delta has really
changed the ballgame with being so
transmissible and contagious we spoke to
dr michael mean at harvard who studies
testing and has been a big advocate for
rapid frequent at-home antigen tests and
you know he believes that if we really
do this
with the right cadence and the right
frequency for example having people test
at home twice a week that that could
help us test to open to stay open for
schools for workplaces so there's a lot
we can do anything that helps us stay
open yeah all right tara thank you
always good to see you